hello and welcome welcome to the
emmanuel center on this cold wintry
night here in London for what I am sure
will be an impassioned intelligence
squared debate absolutely fantastic that
we have pretty well a full house tonight
to debate the motion the West should cut
ties with Saudi Arabia this is an issue
many of you will know which came into
sharp focus in October with the murder
of this prominent Saudi journalist Jamal
khashoggi and the crime is not going
away last night millions of people saw
Jamal smiling face during an ad which
appeared during America's premier
sporting event the Superbowl and the
issue is not going away when it comes to
relations be it political military
economic diplomatic with the Saudi
Kingdom and its de facto ruler Mohammed
bin Salman the crown prince
Saudi Arabia is the driving force in a
devastating war in Yemen but a carries
great political weight across the region
and beyond its carrying out
unprecedented social and economic reform
but there's continuing restrictions on
women's rights and repression of dissent
and Saudi Arabia matters when it comes
to global oil and financial markets the
ties matter but should they be kept or
should they be cut ladies and gentlemen
that is our motion for tonight all of
you who came in here tonight have
already voted on the motion we will soon
hear the opening speeches of our
excellent panel and then I will announce
the results of the first vote all of
what you had to say when you came in
here tonight then there be your
questions
from the floor excellent questions I'm
sure concise and to the point
please don't make the Democratic
moderator into a dictator a third
speaker for the motion is Mehdi Hassan
known I'm sure to many of you prominent
journalists outspoken broadcaster a star
of al Jazeera television he's the host
of up front and head-to-head he is also
a columnist for the intercept
he's host of the deconstruct broadcast
podcast and our first speaker tonight
ladies and gentlemen
ladies and gentlemen good evening I
stand before you tonight to make the
case for the motion and as I do
a number of names and faces flashed
through my mind people are counting on
me and on you tonight to speak for them
in this debate to give them a voice
tonight with your votes Lou Jane
al-hilal for example a young women's
rights activist who was jailed in 2014
for trying to drive her car in Saudi
Arabia upon her release from prison she
went to live in the UAE where last March
she was grabbed on the side of the
freeway put in cuffs thrown on a private
jet and taken back to Saudi Arabia
against her will today aged just 29
years old she sits behind bars for the
temerity of asking for women to have the
right to drive Lou Jane according to her
sister as we speak tonight is being held
in solitary confinement where she's been
beaten waterboarded electrocuted
sexually harassed and threatened with
rape and murder Israel of AMA gong is
also 29 years old she's a young Shiite
human rights activist arrested with her
husband in 2015 for carrying out
peaceful protest not for anything
violent and yet Saudi prosecutors are
seeking to behead her to execute her she
would be the first female human rights
activists to be executed in this way
according to Human Rights Watch Ezra has
not been charged or convicted with any
acts of violence or even anything quote
resembling recognizable crimes the
blogger Raef Badawi
had his 35th birthday last month behind
bars he hasn't seen his kids for seven
years he was sentenced for the crime of
apostasy to ten years in prison and a
thousand lashes lashes fifty of which
he's already had to endure his wife says
his health has deteriorated in prison
and he won't survive another round of
flogging flogging Amal Hussein was seven
years old a little girl in Yemen the
same age as my daughter she posed a
threat to no one and yet there she
wasn't that harrowing photo in the New
York Times last November her emaciated
body her stick-like arms within a week
of that report she was dead literally
starved to
we in the West saw her picture we saw
her haunting eyes and yet we did nothing
to help her we've done nothing to help
the other 1.8 million
severely malnourished children in Yemen
who are suffering from a famine and they
cover a crisis caused by a Saudi imposed
blockade and then there's Jamal
khashoggi Jamal who was sitting with me
in the green room and al-jazeera English
last March as we joked about his
security while the crown prince was in
town in DC less than seven months later
he was dead brutally murdered inside the
Saudi consulate in Istanbul his body
allegedly cut to pieces with a bone saw
and murdered remember according even to
the CIA on the direct orders of the
Saudi Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman
ladies and gentlemen let's not forget
these people tonight in this debate Lou
Jane Ezra rafe Amal Jamal people who
have been killed dismembered tortured
flogged imprisoned starved sexually
assaulted at the hands of our ally our
close friend the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia
tonight we come together to demand
accountability to demand justice to
demand an end to impunity an end to
economic and political blackmail tonight
it's time we make clear that the West
needs to cut its ties with Saudi Arabia
especially military ties arms sales
weapons exports bombs now I'm guessing
we'll hear a lot of what about ISM
tonight from the opposition a lot of
excuse making from the opposition
what about Qatar what about Turkey what
about Iran defenders of Saudi Arabia
often say and those countries yes have
major human rights abuses trust me I
know I've interviewed the leaders of all
of them including the Potteries and ask
them about those human rights issues but
let's be clear tonight's debate is about
Saudi Arabia don't allow yourself to be
distracted by the opposition but also
here's the thing to remember when it
comes to dictatorship when it comes to
women's rights when it comes to the
export of extremism and sectarianism
when it
comes to the funding of terrorism none
of those other countries come close to
Saudi Arabia the Saudis are the premier
league champions at this stuff we all
know that it's not breaking news I doubt
even the Saudi defenders here in this
hall tonight will contest this point
they know it what they'll try and say to
you I'm guessing is that yes knowing
what we know about Saudi Arabia we
should all be concerned we should all be
upset we should all be outraged but we
shouldn't do anything about it we
certainly shouldn't cut any of our ties
because remember the what about ISM what
about the cost of cutting ties with
Saudi Arabia they'll say what about the
fact that our economies need Saudi
Arabia which isn't a fact by the way
it's complete hyperbole in 2017 US
exports to Saudi Arabia accounted for a
whopping 1.1 percent of US exports in
2016 here in the UK British exports to
Saudi Arabia accounted for 1.3 percent
of overall UK exports worldwide what
about the oil they say well the United
States is now the world's biggest
producer of oil in fact the US has
produced more oil than Saudi Arabia for
four straight years in a row by the way
isn't it about time we stopped allowing
the Saudis to use their oil to try and
blackmail the rest of the world what
about intelligence sharing they say what
about the war on terror President Trump
said last November that we can't abandon
the Saudis because and I quote they're
leading the fight against radical
Islamic terrorism what are you kidding
me we're supposed to thank them for
trying to sort out the terrorism problem
that they helped start and before we
forget Saudi Arabia is a load on the
ground in Yemen right now with al Qaeda
they're working with al Qaeda on the
ground according to reporting both by
the BBC and The Associated Press they're
also the second largest source of
foreign fighters to Isis two and a half
thousand Saudis have signed up with that
group and as a leaked US State
Department Cable famously put it donors
in Saudi Arabia constitute the most
significant source of funding to
certainly terrorist groups worldwide
so ladies and gentlemen asking the
Saudis to help lead the fight against
terrorism is like asking the Mafia to
help lead the fight against organized
crime it's like asking Donald Trump and
his kids to lead the fight against
nepotism and corruption it's absurd
let's be serious here there is a reason
why the Algerian novelist Kemal diode
famously wrote that the Kingdom of Saudi
Arabia is basically an Isis that's made
it an isis that's made it so why why why
are we so closely allied with such a
kingdom well what about Iran they say we
need Saudi Arabia against Iran even
though the last time I checked there
were 15 Saudis on those planes not 15
Iranians but even if you're worried
about the threat posed by Iran note how
every step that the Saudis have taken in
recent years has helped and empowered
Iran they bombed Yemen and pushed the
Houthi rebels closer into the arms of
Iran they they blockaded butter and
pushed got their own Iran together they
prompted the Iraqi government to invite
in Iranian militias to fight in Iraq
against insurgent groups many of whom
were quietly backed by the Saudis MBs
mr. bonesaw himself the Saudi Crown
Prince who was behind almost all of
those decisions he's basically the
reverse - everything he turned
everything he touches turns to shit
right it's the reverse
- effect and that is the ally that's the
ally we need to cut ties but that's the
man the ruler who we need to keep our
distance from both metaphorically and
physically and let's be clear this is
not attack this is not about attacking
Saudi Arabia the country I want to be
clear tonight or being aunty the Saudi
people it's about standing up to an
out-of-control and pernicious Saudi
government in fact we've screwed over
the Saudi people for decades opposition
groups religious minorities women's
rights activists journalists dissidents
we have thrown them under the bus by
cozying up to the Saudi regime by
propping up the Saudi regime by
deepening our ties with Riyadh instead
of cutting down our ties with Riyadh
let's also be clear about the wording of
this admittedly awkwardly worded motion
that we have before us cut ties doesn't
mean blockade them or bomb them it
doesn't mean we treat Saudi Arabia like
Saudi Arabia treats Yemen we're not
calling for regime change either but
what it does mean is we know
treat them as our BFF in the Middle East
we no longer supply them with bombs that
they then use with our assistance to
flatten schools hospitals bakeries flour
mills power stations across the poorest
country their Arab world it means we no
longer cover for them at the United
Nations or help get them a seat on the
UN Human Rights Council as David Cameron
so shamelessly did it means we do not
call on our governments to roll out the
red carpet for the Saudis every time
they come to town as Crispin literally
did on the BBC last March roll out the
red carpet for NBS that's what we mean
by cutting ties tonight that's what
we're arguing for that's what we want
you to vote for tonight because ladies
no man there's a lot of people out there
watching this debate they're gonna be
watching on YouTube elsewhere Saudi
princes Saudi trolls arms dealers the
torture is outside Luger now hospitals
prison cell we need to send them a
message
tonight we draw a line in the sand and
we say no more we will not allow you to
thumb your nose at international law we
will not allow you to ignore basic
global norms of decency and human rights
we will not allow you to get away with
cold-blooded murder in Istanbul we will
not allow you to strangle an entire
country and create the biggest
humanitarian crisis in the world ladies
and gentlemen you all know full well
that is well past time to draw that line
in the sand to cut ties with Saudi
Arabia so stop treating them as a lie a
friend when they are none of the above
send that message tonight vote for the
motion tonight thank you very much for
your time
your hands look at tired if you clap too
long for every speaker ladies and
gentlemen our first speaker against the
motion who very much enjoyed Mehdi
Hassan's intervention Mamun Fondy
Egyptian born expert on the Middle East
eloquent speaker or so they say
he's the president of the London
think-tank London global strategy
Institute and he's the author of Saudi
Arabia and the politics of dissent mom
would find his interest I'm told include
politics of the Arab world terrorism and
radical Islamic politics regional
security issues in the region and
definitely intelligence squared since he
came out of his sick bed tonight to join
us please welcome him latest
thank you good evening and I would like
to thank the organizers very much for
inviting me to participate in this I
have to admit it's certainly very
difficult to come after the young and
handsome body with a full head of hair
to argue against the motion I would like
to really take issues with three areas
that I would like to debate calmly and
dispassionately one one is the issue of
should the West should the worst cut
ties with Saudi Arabia what West when
we're talking about an international
system made of nation-states an
international order that's made of
international law so the idea that there
is something called a West suggests a
great deal of hierarchy in values that
the west can act on behalf of
international law on behalf of humanity
that Africa doesn't exist
Asia doesn't exist nowhere else the
morally superior West can act on behalf
of everybody else and cut ties with with
Saudi Arabia I mean we've seen how the
West acts in 2003 on the attack on Iran
and if the case of the horrible murder
of Jamar yogi in Istanbul and the
alleged cut off parts of his body as my
dessert one can all do also look at Abu
Ghraib prisons worse did the West cut
ties with the United States the United
States was the unisys brought to an
international crime tribunal for these
abuses so the idea of really just
creating a special yardsticks for
countries that we don't like is not very
helpful for the notion of international
law and
my dear friend Maddy said he is not
really against Saudi Arabia and he is
not insulting Saudi Arabia but in the
same breath he said Saudi Arabia's and
Isis that made it so it is the same
attitude that people take if you don't
like a country can use epithets and so
on just to make a point now Saudi Arabia
is certainly not a Jeffersonian
democracy but Saudi Arabia is a country
that's made out of the desert sand and
it continued probably for the last 300
years various generations and it's very
important for Muslims worldwide for 1
billion Muslims who pray 5 times to
Mecca every day Saudi Arabia is very
important so the idea of just taking
Saudi Arabia lightly like any other
small state like talking about small
Lincoln Stein or pinene or something
like that then we're really missing the
whole point
Saudi Arabia is also as least pointed
out very central to the stability of the
global order of energy and all of us
those who old enough
remember the cutting of oil in the war
in 1973 the boycott by the Arab states
and the kind of devastating effect that
created for the international economy
Saudi Arabia is also very important for
regional stability it is not a small
state it's a very important state and I
don't think we should throw the baby
with the bathwater because one horrible
crime was committed
I take issues with my friend Maddy who
made a point of Gamal khashoggi and
Gamal in the same way that he's a friend
of Marty's a friend of mine and it pains
me to talk about
him that way but I would remind my teeth
at the same probably two days later
after the death of the Mahakali or the
disappearance of the Malkovich Joey a
Bulgarian journalist Victoria Minerva
was killed raped and murdered in Sofia
nobody helped the the regime in Bulgaria
accountable EE even talked about it or
mentioned it because we just measure
global issues with different yardsticks
I don't mind at all
that we call on Saudi Arabia to respect
human rights and so they're able to
abide by the rule of law but certainly
we don't give a pass for everybody else
because we don't like Saudi Arabia very
importantly I think all of us have to
reflect on on on some of these issues
when when one talks about should the
west again should the West cut off ties
with Saudi Arabia is very much like
saying should Canada lead on the problem
in Venezuela I mean this is these are
non-starters in real politic and the
world of sane men and women who
considered the world at large not one
single issue at a time I wonder those of
you who want the West to cut off ties
can tell me how do we cut off ties and
did it work anywhere else I mean the
United States cut off ties with Cuba for
god knows how many years half a century
and Cuba remain Castro remained and Cuba
became worse the conditions of the Cuban
people did not improve the United States
car of relationship with Iran since the
Revolution of 1979 the Iranian regime
still with us 14 years later the United
States cut off ties with North Korea
embarked in ice
trying to cut deals with with West Korea
so when we talk about how can we do this
I mean as sane reasonable people it's
reasonable to call in Saudi Arabia to
respect human rights it is reasonable to
have very targeted sanctions against
individuals for who committed crimes but
it is not reasonable to just isolate a
whole country secondly argue against
Marty here first of all in the world of
sovereign Stein's where every nation is
sovereign has its own laws and
regulations
why Saudi Arabia is different sorry Reba
came to us and said there is half
judicial process in place to try those
who committed the crime in Istanbul
what's wrong with waiting for this
process to end I understand a chuckle
here and a chat over but I think as sane
people we have to have a respect for
National Mall as well as international
law but the idea of a crowd deciding all
of us did scut off relationship with
this country or that country with no
respect for international law or no no
respect for national law then we are in
the world of a jungle I mean how do we
organize a very complex international
community along those lines of the
winners are the people that the crowd
decides who how to punish people this is
just basically unacceptable in a very
complex world
Saudi Arabia decided that it will take
issues with those committed the crime
now all of us there is a great deal of
assumptions the the Crown Prince of
Saudi Arabia is behind this thing I
would like to see video or an audio or
something like that
that links Mohammed bin Salman to this
crime I have yet to say I mean this is
here we are in quote-unquote the West
where there is due process and and
people are innocent until proven guilty
somehow we decided this man order things
and he is absolutely guilty for
committing this crime making it making
these leaps and jumps just defies reason
and and I think my problems somebody who
came from Egypt who got education in the
West and believed in quote/unquote the
values of the West I still believe that
people are innocent until proven guilty
but just jumping frog hopping here and
there try to dink points that are not
linked to satisfy and revenge that's
burning inside us and taking some
scapegoat somewhere and linking a whole
regime in the whole country to one crime
I think it's just I would probably refer
it as immature and romantic notion of
international politics
please the gentleman Mahmud Fundy also
young also handsome our second speaker
for the motion professor but are we all
receive he's a leading thinker on Saudi
Arabia she is from the kingdom and her
latest book is salman legacy the dilemma
of a new era in saudi arabia but how al
Rasheed is the professor of social
anthropology in the Middle East center
at the London School of Economics ladies
and gentlemen she has debated two other
times this very issue that we confront
tonight she won one debate she lost one
debate three times lucky or unlucky
ladies and gentlemen up to you to decide
badal we are Rashid
good evening ladies and gentlemen it's a
pleasure for me to participate in this
debate for the third time I will keep
doing it as long as I have to and thank
you for inviting me to be part of this
panel as you have noticed I am the only
woman on the panel and I'm also the only
Saudi person on the panel but let me put
the Saudi word in inverted commas
because I need to tell you about a
little history that is very personal
I came to Britain in 1983 as a young
student who wanted to pursue her
education and the most esteemed
universities in Britain I went to
Cambridge I did my master and also I did
my PhD as I finished my PhD in social
anthropology looking at the history of
Saudi Arabia my father got a phone call
from nobody but Prince Salman at the
time he was the governor of Riyadh and
Prince Salman conveyed the information
to my father that if I published my PhD
thesis I will be subjected to
disciplinary action whatever that means
well of course I went ahead and
published my dissertation and published
another 1415 books after
I remain I remain Saudi living in
Britain moving to different jobs
becoming a professor at the British
universities here in London first at
King's College and then I moved to LSE
but in 2005 I got another phone call
from my father who was informed by the
king of Saudi Arabia that my salary
nationality was withdrawn sir luckily I
was a British citizen by that stage why
was it withdrawn because I went on
television to object to the fact that
Saudi women were deprived of
participating as voters and candidates
in the municipal elections we're not
talking here about national elections a
parliament god forbid because in the
South the Islamic tradition our
Constitution is the Quran and there is
no need for elected parliament because
the King knows it all and he can decide
for everybody so I lost my Saudi
passport but my story is not unique
you probably have heard in the last two
weeks the story about raha falcone hoon
who escaped from Saudi Arabia ended up
in Thailand and then Canada luckily
accepted her as an asylum seeker
according to the United Nation UNHCR
there are now 2 over 2000 Saudi asylum
seekers going to the United States to
Canada and Britain so this wealthy
country where we are told that British
expats love to go and work on there and
earn untaxed salaries are want to go to
that country we find that the Saudi men
and women are leaving the country so if
you're worried about migration and
asylum seekers we are heading towards a
crisis in Saudi Arabia today Saudi
Arabia is
pressure cooker on the verge of
implosion simply because the so-called
reforms of the Crown Prince Mohammed bin
Salman who is held by the international
media from the New York time to the
Washington Post to our press here in
Britain is the great revolutionary
reformer he allows Saudis to go to
concerts and he allows women to attend
football matches if accompanied by their
male Guardians
so this top-down revolution that is
happening is producing asylum seekers is
producing the people the real people who
have been mentioned by my colleague
Mehdi Hassan
so from women activists from that people
who are simply tweeting people who are
at university my colleague hatun al fasi
she studied in Manchester University she
is an archaeologist specializing in
deciphering the inscription of the
Nabatean civilization in the north of
Saudi Arabia that Mohammed bin Salman
wants to become a tourist attraction
encouraging you the educated audience to
go and see these archaeological sites
each specializes in deciphering the
inscriptions of this ancient
civilization she is now in prison and
has been since June 2018 her crime
nobody knows according to the Saudi
Press we have the front pages of this
cell do newspapers talking about these
women activists who had been put in jail
as traitors as agents of foreign
governments I myself are is called also
a traitor an agent of the British
intelligence services simply because I
write books enjoy the freedom of speech
that this country allows me and my own
country deprives me of so if we're
talking I do agree with my colleague
Mamoon when we
say the West I don't like these
generalizations in as much as I don't
like the idea that there is a Muslim
world out there or an Arab world no
we're talking about individual countries
in Britain for example we are always
told that we can't shun those people who
torture their own citizens who bomb
other countries we have to have
constructive engagement with them a
dialogue with them my colleague here the
right honourable gentleman Crispin asked
the Saudi embassy to allow him to go to
Saudi Arabia or allow a team to
investigate the alleged torture of women
activists and what did the Saudi embassy
do didn't reply I understand sir
the constructive engagement is supposed
to in the British government's rhetoric
successive government is meant to do
behind the door diplomacy and be it talk
about the British citizens who are
tortured in Saudi prisons we won't talk
about them publicly but we will put
pressure on the Saudi government to
change its behavior so far I do not see
any change of behavior women activists
are put in prison tortured also and I
cannot see that this situation has
changed so the domestic situation is
really bad but we can't express or
expect different Western government to
cut ties with Saudi Arabia by cutting
ties I mean the different Western
governments should suspend their
unconditional support for the Saudi
regime and underline the word
unconditional support
so when MBS 4 does the killing of a
journalist he until now we don't give
him an ultimatum
whereas we give the Venezuelan president
and ultimatum to have elections
and we don't regard that as interfering
in the sovereignty of the Venezuelan
people but when it comes to Saudi Arabia
oh no no we can't interfere because
those people are ruled by Sharia some
kind of Islamic law that they are not
like us we exhaust sighs them we make
Saudis look as if they are
extraterrestrial that they are governed
by a law that is not shared by humanity
when the Saudi regime abuses its own
people it's violating international
values and norms and we have to be
responsible for that at the
international level how do we boycott a
country how do you put pressure on a
country well my friend gave the example
of Cuba but remember that Britain the US
are the main suppliers of the weapons
that Saudi Arabia uses to destabilize
the region rather than create stability
in Lebanon they forced their prime
minister to resign to precipitate a
crisis in Bahrain they intervened to
derail the democracy impulse in 2011 and
in Qatar
they fractured the solidarity of Gulf
countries in Yemen I don't need to tell
you about Yemen the poorest country of
the Arab world so ladies and gentlemen
you are an educated audience your vote
is extremely important because you're
sending a message to our government here
in Britain and around the world as this
debate will be seen by so many people
outside this country you are sending a
debate rejecting this unconditional
support the carte blanche that the Saudi
regime gets from different Western
countries thank you very much
thank you too Madhavi al-rasheed last
but not least our last speaker against
the motion Crispin Blount regarded as
one of the most experienced foreign
policy voices in the UK Parliament of
course you may say how many foreign
policy voices are there in the UK
Parliament it's a voice that's often
heard on Saudi Arabia as Madhavi Al
Rashid mentioned he was part of an MP's
panel that went to Saudi Arabia to
consider the jail conditions for Saudi
women activists it was published today
and concluded that their jail conditions
could be akin to torture he's the
Conservative MP for Reigate chair and he
was chair of the House of Commons
Foreign Affairs Select Committee from
2015 to 2017
welcome to crisp and blunt against the
thank you very much for that
introduction and good evening ladies and
gentlemen many thanks to intelligence
squared for organizing its debate and
inviting me to speak on the side of the
of the opposition nothing bumpy about
this particular track I'm battling on
but many thanks to the previous speakers
who have Illustrated many of the issues
at stake here and during my 21 years as
a Conservative member of parliament I
have consistently defended the Kingdom
of Saudi Arabia's important relationship
with the United Kingdom and I have
supported continuing UK arms exports to
the saudi-led coalition operating with
unanimous international endorsement in
the Yemen and indeed as was been pointed
out I did welcome the visit of Crown
Prince Mohammed bin Salman to the UK
last year and I suspect many of you
without knowing who I am seeing that a
Conservative member of parliament was
arguing against this motion might have
been unsurprised unchallenged by your
expectations however I hope you are
ready to hear a more nuanced point of
view and that I can challenge your
expectations now I first met Mohammed
bin Salman when leading a commons
Foreign Affairs Committee on a visit to
Riyadh in December 2015 and over a
meeting lasting an hour and a half I
confess I was impressed by his strategic
grass man his ability to engage on all
questions on on all fronts I've also
made countless diplomatic and
parliamentary visits to the region since
1993 when I became the foreign
secretaries then special advisor so I
hope I have a decent understanding of
the realities of the region at least by
parliamentary standards
therefore it is I who perhaps am most
disappointed with the current state of
the kingdom and I have acute anxieties
for its future and the implications that
has for the region and to that end I
hope you will have the chance to glance
at this report that I am to
parliamentary colleagues Leyla Moran and
dr. Paul Williams have published today
it was a
tenshun review panel examining the
conditions of eight female detainees and
four of their male supporters and indeed
the name that Mehdi gave first in his
speech is the first listed here whose
case we reviewed and I accepted the task
of reviewing the detention conditions of
these women's rights activists and their
male supporters partly because I hoped I
would command the confidence of both
Saudi Arabia and its critics are
actually being fair I'm the man who
chaired a Foreign Affairs Committee
report on brakes it three times three
different reports and brought them all
home unanimously despite a committee
split down the middle and I hoped that
my engagement with the Gulf monarchies
and public appreciation for the
stability those rulers have brought to
the Gulf Cooperation Council would lead
to cooperation from their Kingdom
emphasizing the panel's honest and
independent nature however as I've
already made clear I am incredibly
disappointed by the series of events
that lie behind tonight's debate and the
murder of Jamal khashoggi
provides the most gruesome backdrop and
lease are made clear that our report can
take concluded that the detainees have
been subjected to cruel and inhumane
treatments including sleep deprivation
assault threats to life and solitary
confinement and their treatment is
likely to amount to torture and if they
are not providing with urgent access to
medical assistance they are at risk of
developing long-term health conditions
torture is a crime of universal
jurisdiction and no nation that can
claim to be a liberal democracy can in
all conscience allow such heinous crimes
to go unanswered so of course we must
evaluate our ties with Saudi Arabia we
must show the benefits of openness on
society we have a duty to help Britain
has levers of influence in the kingdom
and we should be intent on pulling them
to influence where we can indeed I
believe we have a moral responsibility
to do so the picture in Saudi Arabia is
as complex as the personality of its
young
crown prince the moves of Mohammed bin
Salman towards economic reform with
vision 2030 have been accompanied by
wider social reform the removal of
arrest powers from the religious police
they have actually prepared the
legislation for the easing of male
guardianship laws although it remains to
be implemented and the granting of
women's right to drive and the opening
of public places or of entertainment
stands as an incongruous contradiction
when you lock up the individuals who
were calling for these things in the
first place and I want to state very
plainly that the attitude and the
actions of the kingdom cannot be
tolerated and it has to be seen how our
government in 2019 will recast its
relations with Saudi Arabia not only in
the light of the murder Jamarcus og but
with the active suppression of civil
society that should accompany any claims
of a monarchy that wishes to be at least
overtly consultative but we must address
the motion itself I agree with the
analysis about the term of the West and
how difficult that is so I'm going to
focus principally on the United Kingdom
but cutting ties which I interpret is
cutting all ties otherwise this debate
is simply about semantics is a rare step
in a diplomatic ass indeed a full
unambiguous severing of ties is not a
simple action we reserve such decisions
for countries we are at war with or who
seek to subvert our institutions the
United Kingdom expelled 23 Russian
diplomats in the wake of Russia's proved
involvement in the attempted murder of
the scree files and the death of dawn
sturgis sending a strong diplomatic
signal that Russia is a bad faith
international actor and I am now under
no illusions that the status quo with
Saudi Arabia is acceptable however
cutting all ties would amount to both
self harm and harm to the cause of
reform in Saudi Arabia but cutting some
ties in certain areas may and indeed
should be carried out but defense our
principle relationship illustrates the
dilemma
I've historically
offended British arms tails to the
kingdom and although a revaluation of
our defense relationship must be on the
table severing this link would probably
be highly detrimental to global security
in the long term whilst obviously
painful for our economy and defense
industry but more importantly we live in
a loose liberal democratic rules based
world order underpinned by NATO the u.s.
security on umbrella and of course the
United Nations this has not always been
the case and indeed it may be in reverse
indeed as a liberal democracy we should
do all in our power to prevent more
authoritarian countries who place less
value on the rule of law from becoming
the dominant paradigm of the world
cutting totally defense ties with Saudi
Arabia would be a gift to increasing the
values of China and Russia on the world
stage right now we have been able to
improve their conduct of the Yemen
operation and help them bring the
Houthis and themselves and their allies
to the peace table one of the ironies of
the relative ineffectiveness of the
Saudi military efforts that have seen
thousands die is that millions are now
at the risk of starvation and I don't
think that's anything many of this in
this room would wish for a full
disengagement with Saudi Arabia's armed
forces will remove whatever British
oversight exists and do you really want
to drive Saudi Arabia towards the
re-education camps of Jang Jing of
Russian conduct in Chechnya and Syria
and that these countries who place such
wretchedly low value on human rights the
integrity of the individual and the rule
of law but let me illustrate with
another dilemma over justice I was
dismayed when in 2015 Britain cancelled
the contract for the Ministry of Justice
to provide training for prison staff in
Saudi Arabia which had the admirable
goal of providing advice on the
improvement of its detention system and
I still maintain that that cancellation
was populist nonsense and whilst it may
have been popular and achieved nothing
but a sense of moral satisfaction for
the United Kingdom we were able to
assure ourselves that we had no part of
plan a justice system which
execute for offenses that might not even
be crimes in the United Kingdom but we
gave up on the chance to improve the
Saudi prison system and people don't
respond well when they're scorned for
doing something wrong no one likes to be
told on a bad day even me that they're
wrong it's much better to offer a
solution to engage and to explain to the
other side why an alternative might be
better
megaphone diplomacy and the noisy condo
nations will always be heard humiliating
the decision-makers of course public
shaming and isolation of offending
regimes has a place and can be a spur to
progress but in our instance thumbing
our noses
sadly prisons merely hardened their
attitudes and leading to the current
wretched state of detention which was
one of the reasons I was happy to chair
this panel now Saudi Arabia has
acknowledged
once upon a time under King Abdullah who
said that reason rules the world ethics
rules the world and these can rule the
world this can and should be the case
but we need to drag Mohammed bin Salman
along these lines with Oliver parts of
pressure we can adopt otherwise we have
the prospect of an absolute monarchy
ruled ruling terror totally closing down
the space for civil society in Saudi
Arabia and in the end there will be
revolution and what will follow will be
infinitely worse than what they have now
ladies and gentlemen a big thank you
Crispin Blunt for speaking against the
motion and a big thank you to all of our
speakers please give them another round
of applause
excellent speakers on a very important
motion the West should cut ties with
Saudi Arabia this is how you voted when
you came in the Emmanuel Center this
evening for the vote 41% of you said the
West should cut ties with Saudi Arabia
41% twenty two of you were against and a
big 37 percent of you came into this
hall tonight undecided and perhaps you
are making up your mind right now and I
was a time for you to ask your questions
where's number one where my number one
who's gonna have the the honor of asking
the first excellent question hi thank
you so much I thought it was a really
interesting debate and like I'm really
glad that I attended I wanted to ask
that the speakers for the motion that if
the West does cut ties with Saudi Arabia
which I like agree with all of your
points how do we ensure that the same
thing doesn't happen in terms of civil
war like has happened in other Arab
nations thank you
right over here number two a related
point which which is that we're very
concerned in this country about the
cutting of ties between Britain and
Europe which could come about through a
brexit if we have this cutting of ties
between the west and Saudi Arabia what
comes after this Saudi Arabia is such a
central pillar of such an unstable part
of the world that proposition have
completely failed to talk about what
comes if they succeed in their desire to
get to change a regime which they see as
being abhorrent thank you and way in the
back number three it was question for
mr. Blum you talked about countries that
seek to subvert our institutions but
when bae systems were investigated for
bribing saudi officials the psy.d
government threatened British lives on
British streets
and it was withdrawn so I don't see them
respecting our institutions for some
punch we'll have a minute to think about
that Midori al-rasheed the first two
questions were Buffy the same what will
happen it could be civil war could be
something worse if ties are cuts no well
the assumption that if the Saudi regime
Falls then we're gonna have a civil war
like in Syria and Libya etc but we
forget that the Saudi regime itself
played an incredible central role in
turning syria into a sectarian war
rather than a pre democracy movement
that wanted to gain all the rights that
we enjoy here the saudis were the second
cohort of jihadis who went to Syria to
derail that impulse towards democracy
and Saudi Arabia is not just about
conservatives and about jihadis of
course the name the Saudi regime is
associated with violence that is
practiced by terrorists in the name of
Islam but inside did a study of a group
of Saudis who are who were calling for
civil society exactly what Christian was
talking about those people had all been
imprisoned let's take the question the
question was but whatever your
disagreements with the kingdom now if
you cut ties it will get worse what can
I jump in on the stability point I mean
the stability point Mamun mentioned it
as well sorry what stability if you
checked out the Middle East recently
what stability we're referring to so yes
a central pillar of an unstable region
also one of the central causes of the
instability in that region and you say
we didn't make the case Midori went
through the list Lebanon they kidnapped
the Prime Minister allegedly MBS slapped
him around Qatar they undermined the
Gulf Cooperation Council with a blockade
that hasn't worked two years later Syria
madhavi's made the point they helped
ferment the jihadist part of the
opposition we all know what's happening
in Yemen where they're literally working
with al-qaeda on the ground I thought we
were worried about al-qaeda I thought we
were fighting a war on terror for 17
years
of course don't forget Saudi Arabia is
one of the key forces with Netanyahu in
Israel and John Bolton wanting to push
for a new war in the Middle East in Iran
which will make you rock there like a
walk-in the boss
so what pillars answer to the question
will it get worse you cut ties you're
focusing on what there is now I'm not
gonna play counterfactuals it's worse
now we're complicit in a war in Yemen
now I want to stop our complicity now
not not deal with kind of hypotheticals
that it might get worse it's horrible
now and Saudis a big part of that once
we heard question about the BAE Systems
and what you call constructive
engagement is she mentions threats
I confess I haven't heard the explicit
Saudi threat to British citizens on
British on British streets however what
I am pleased about is the fact that our
country not only has the toughest arms
exports controls alright that I found
globally but also has passed both
parties supported the passing the
bribery act in in 2010 to make sure that
our standards are consistently the
highest the highest in the world there
will always have been things wrong in
the in the past of course of course
there have but what we need to what we
need to be committed to is consistent
improvement and what we also need to be
committed to is to try and rescue Saudi
Arabia from the threat in the end of
revolution and if revolution happens in
Saudi Arabia do not think that there is
going to be some nice cosy regime
perhaps led by the Al Rashid family who
replaced by the sides in the first very
first part of the 20th century what will
follow is like it's likely to be very
very ugly indeed very briefly and ask
Crispin one quick question in your
speech you spent the you spent the
second half of your speech telling us
that we have levers of influence over
Saudi Arabia and you ended by saying it
is much better to engage and explain and
you spent the first half of your speech
telling us how the Saudis wouldn't let
you in I want you a walking example of
why engagement an explanation doesn't
work you should be on this side of the
house tonight surely
and that and obviously that depends on
your definition of ties I am against
cutting all ties with sadly rates and of
course there needs to be measures taken
against Saudi Arabia for obviously the
appalling murder of Jamarcus yogi but it
is but it is but it is it is right to
wait for at least there is a Saudi
justice system operating putting on
trial for what happened there in total
in total difference to any to the
Russian view as to what they did about
the the attempt to murder the street
bars and indeed the Honorable ladies and
gentlemen of the floor question number
four I am thank you so much for
everybody so tonight it's been
fascinating and firstly and so crispin I
just want to take issue with the
attitude you say that Britain has a
civilizing influence on Saudi and there
seems slightly almost harken back to
colonial times to myself I mean given
the fact that we have the war in Yemen
as discussed atrocities wrote upon its
own people and this just seems patently
false but my question really is that
because the u.s. alliance with Saudi is
a large in a large degree two part of
its blanket support for Israel against
Iran in the region what will it take to
remove the support right here question
every tube from the floor
north Korea has it's useful idiots in
the UK and probably elsewhere in the
form of tourists tour operators and
travel writers who do their damnedest to
whitewash the regime or to delude
visitors that they're seeing the real
North Korea if Saudi opens up to tourism
isn't that a risk of the same thing
happening doing immeasurable harm to
those of us who are campaigning for
human rights there so I'd like to ask
one or both of the speakers for the
motion to say what can be done to
prevent tourism taking over okay one
let's take this gentleman here right in
the front row and then we have one in
the back
the debates been very much framed in
terms of human rights but I'd like to
ask the audience to change the paradigm
and look at this from a perspective of
what is in the the real political
interests of Britain is Saudi a threat
or not to the UK the export of terrorism
from Saudi religious fundamentalism etc
and how would Saudi compared to other
significant countries in the region if I
were to March and coming down to earth
why is it that the West is historically
so close to Saudi Arabia as opposed to
other regimes in the region which might
appear to be more liberal okay and we're
gonna take one here in this corner
very good this is to the opposition do
you not think that by not cutting ties
with Saudi Arabia we are telling
authoritarian regimes that they can
essentially do what they want and that
the West what moral responsibilities are
essentially worthless when it really
matters
someone would you would you like to
respond to the question I'd like to
respond to my 31st because I think Mandy
made a point but I'd like Saudi Arabia
almost the ISIS that made it all the
time and this most horrible country on
the face of alright
but the point is imagine I mean if Saudi
Arabia goes radical as he imagined it it
would make Isis look like the Green
Party of Germany I challenge the
opposition it is challenged the
opposition if they count if they can
name more than the eight women activists
in Saudi prisons I challenge them beyond
legend as well but in the region where
countries in the neighborhoods have
sixty thousand fifty thousand political
prisoners these are I'm not saying -
what I'm saying is there is a principle
of proportionality a country of 23
million has a women that's does
Crispin's report not bother you bothers
me but what I'm saying is that we have
to be mature enough to know the
countries in the region it ran for
example has like a hundred thousand to
to the prisons Egypt my home country has
between fifty and sixty political
thousands so let's come back to having
it again Saudi Arabia is insane I mean
just like politically insane - you don't
give you know I applaud you for taking
the moral high ground and one would it
kind of expect nothing less one would
hope of a young idealist asking you a
question like that
the only
[Music]
I look quite sure why I said something
wrong and describing which the young the
young Toriyama he I rather I rather hope
you're an idealist but no but the
problem but the problem for policy
makers is if you camp out on the moral
high ground and you absolve yourself of
responsibility so what follows you may
then have to cope with what is going to
follow because you've taken that option
it is in many ways it'll be the easy
thing to do to say that we should cut
all ties and have nothing more to do
with them but then we have nothing more
to do with the consequences of what will
follow and I am profoundly anxious about
what may now happen in Saudi Arabia and
I think we should be bending every
effort to try and get Saudi Arabia back
onto a track towards progress that is
both economic progress and also social
progress his specific question was and
we should have yeah mr. tsuda question
was won't it send a signal to others
that they can get away with it not just
Saudi Arabia will have a ripple effect
and the consequence of what we do will
then be to drive them into the hands of
nations like Russia and China whose
moral code is not one that I think any
of us should want to share or support
and that would be the consequence of
taking of taking that position it's the
world is full of horrible hard choices
lady would you like to take the human
rights question just the question which
is which is why is there a threat all of
this is being focused on human rights
we had a gentleman asking well what
threat is there to the United Kingdom I
mean I completely agree I mean we I
don't I don't I didn't push it in my
speech because you know I have an issue
with the whole war on terror discourse
but I do find it odd the people on the
right who told us for years that we
should be worried about terrorists under
every bet who tell us that Muslims are
all extremists who tell us that mosques
of funding radicalism don't seem to care
that one of the major countries perhaps
the major country behind a lot of the
ideology is Saudi Arabia that's what
even right-wing think tanks like Henry
Jackson Freddie which I'm no fan of
produce reports saying Saudi Arabia is
the foremost chief proponent of Islamist
funding in the UK so I do find that to
be a problem and this is not just a
moral point the young gentleman a very
good point this is not just about
morality you talk about this is about
consequences if you say to them you can
do whatever you want if they kidnap the
Lebanese Prime Minister if they blockade
Qatar if they carry on funding jihadists
in Syria if they kill journalists in
consulate British citizens accusing them
of manufacturing alcohol putting them in
Saudi jails so we're talking about
30,000 British expats who live in Saudi
but if they do all this without any
consequence that is a problem and sorry
this is not about liberal or young
people Lindsey Graham Senator Lindsey
Graham who you know well one of the most
hawkish Republican members of the Senate
hardcore supporter of Saudi Arabia says
and I quote we don't want to give a
green light to others that they can go
down this road he says he will not
support Saudi Arabia while it is run by
this reckless crown prince and he is no
liberal would you like to know we're not
asking every British citizen in this
whole to care about the plight of Saudi
detainees yes I don't want to get stuck
in a human rights argument we are
realists we understand politics but it
is in the interest of the British people
not to have unconditional support for
air gym like Saudi Arabia in 1980
somebody asked the question about how
they corrupt our institutions here in
Britain you're absolutely right in 1980
Saudi Arabia cut diplomatic relations
with Britain because there was a brief
film shown on one of the British channel
called death of Princess about a
princess who wanted to marry a commoner
and she was beheaded right so nine
months of no diplomatic relations
between Saudi Arabia and Britain in just
last summer when a Canadian foreign
minister criticized the detention of
women activists
what did Saudi Arabia do morons they
kicked out the Canadian ambassador and
and Germany criticized Saudi Arabia when
it tried to destabilize Lebanon what
happened they canceled all the armed
cells with Germany Sweden again women
activists the plight of women activists
and the situation in Saudi Arabia was
criticized in Sweden and immediately
they call the passport yes
Saudi Arabia doesn't behave in a
civilized manner when it comes to
diplomatic relations yes Britain didn't
cut diplomatic relations with Russia
after they killed they attempted to kill
two Russians and on our soil here but
Saudi Arabia is very quick to to cut
relations with Britain if Britain
uttered one word of criticism if we take
the example of Canada and the rest of
the
so exhausting there was a question to
you about your use of the word
civilizing influence and question which
was looking also at the relationship but
let's be clear the last thing I'm
arguing for is unconditional support for
for Saudi Arabia roll out the red carpet
for MBS yes because that is not that is
not the same thing and having having
having having message to Saudi Arabia
having less in addition having having
met him and and been I confess impressed
by his this this young man being
presented to us as we were briefed
before we went in you will be surprised
by the his his his grasp of his grasp of
affairs which was one to one or one to
four and and the MPs there over a
prolonged period is impressive he this
is why he went to the United States and
wild audiences from one end of the
United States to the other and had the
ability to communicate with other people
of the complexity we have got to deal
with this is the same guy who almost
certainly gave approved the operation
that against Jamal kesaji
this is the same guy whose intelligence
or chief intelligence officer appears to
have overseen the mistreatment of women
detainees in Saudi Arabia this is the
same guy who has now drawn all levers of
power into his own hands in Saudi Arabia
and yes I think the best thing will be
frankly is if Saudi Arabia could find
itself another ruler of course whether
you will then going to overthrow the
entire system on that basis is another
question but that is going to be a
decision for the Saudis to take question
number one piece as a convert to Islam
when I was twenty years old that was
five years ago
I I would like to ask the the panel both
Versailles isn't Saudi Arabia complicit
in this ex this export of fundamentalist
puritanical jihadi concepts and it's
infected mosques and young people all
over the Western world don't don't you
think that somebody should call the the
governments of the West need to call
Saudi Arabia to account for what they're
doing and they're funding these mega
preachers are you saying they should
excuse me were you saying that she cut
ties or keep ties they should cut ties
with sell Europe in some form or another
you don't hold them responsible for
their distortion of Islam which has has
led so much
[Applause]
hello night RV I'm from the Kingdom of
Saudi Arabia
and why the people who speak positively
about Saudi Arabia are voiceless I moved
to the West in 2014 and they learned a
lot from the West and actually I am the
founder of the first interfaith
organization inside Saudi Arabia and if
you cut ties with Saudi Arabia how are
you gonna change the people how are you
gonna change the minds 2014 I was
watching al-jazeera
and that's the platform of Osama bin
Laden and that's a lot of problems was
there I lost a lot of family members
because terrorists attack inside Saudi
Arabia and what I want to talk
assertively about Saudi Arabia I don't
really have a voice and as Mahdi say
your question sir as mahdi said I am a
troll so that's what's going on why the
Saudi citizen who talked positive about
their country are voiceless in the
Western media that's it thank you sir
and way up in the back so it's just to
gain a bit more clarity and specificity
really from the proponents on the motion
of exactly how this would play out so
should the West cut ties to Saudi Arabia
it's a it's open to some interpretation
okay it's got some ambiguity in there so
a variety of different policy positions
and examples from around the world and
throughout history have been alluded to
so far so one person mentioned Venezuela
and the way in which the West has
exerted pressure on them but without
entirely cutting off ties with them the
opponents of the motion have repeatedly
referenced North Korea Iran and Cuba as
examples of countries where we have
entirely completely cut off ties there
are but there are a few other countries
which also bear worth mentioning so for
example in South Africa during the
apartheid era there were specific
targeted sanctions and which had certain
demands upon them it wasn't we're gonna
cauterize with you forever it was your
question and whether it's possible to
maintain ties but do something short of
cutting my question to the
opponents the motion is specifically if
you were the Foreign Minister for the UK
what would be your exact precise
strategy what would be your policy so
without the height without the sort of
recess in a moral position what exactly
what strategies would use you've you've
talked about not rolling out the red
carpet you've talked about not selling
arms but what other concrete practical
strategies would you adopt okay that's
something that perhaps we can deal with
in a bit more in a bit more in a bit
more with more depth but let me so
you've given the role of the Foreign
Minister of the United Kingdom I think
if you've given that to crispin or to
Mamun or may be timid are we actually
Mamun that some let's get you to we
we've heard that wish that the best way
to stop the distortion of Islam is to
cut off ties it's in a very strong way
I'm not sure you know there is a great
deal of factual errors being peddled
here when we talk about Saturday be
spreading radical Islam you have to
remind people that it was the basic
radical organization started in Egypt in
1928 under said cut of the ultimate
ideologue of Salafi jihadi ISM Isabella
Arnold now Judy came from subcontinent I
did NEP decide that there is a Saudi who
has the same standing as now duty or I
said koto or as Hassan al-banna
there is none I mean these are followers
they is Saudi Arabia was taken over by
the Muslim Brotherhood at some point
when NASA drove a man and drove them out
of Egypt then speak present ski during
the Cold War recruited Saudis recruited
Saudis to go and fight in Afghanistan as
part of mini client states and under the
leadership of none other than or sama
bin Laden has my friend pointed out the
the very close friend of al Qaeda of Al
Jazeera Network who had the exclusive
rights to all his tapes and interviews
so this is
being peddled yes the theory is the
bedrock question from the kingdom yeah
he's asking why do you why don't you
give more positive news about what's
happening in Saudi Arabia lots of
positive news the idea that positive
news about Saudi Arabia is missing on
the idea that Saudis don't have a voice
in the Western media Saudi Arabia has
one of the biggest army of lobbyists of
any country in the Western world they
have op-eds conference I live in
Washington DC there a conference his
think-tank sponsored by the Saudi
government all the time there are op eds
and US newspapers sponsored some of them
are written by the Saudi government
handed out to US politicians to publish
under their name so this is absurd the
idea that Saudi Arabia doesn't get a
hearing in the Western press as for the
idea that Al Jazeera is a friend of bin
Laden it's an absurd claim been made for
many years but I find it ironic that Al
Jazeera is being blamed for Osama bin
Laden who was a Saudi national last time
I checked and just one point I must make
man when finally he was stripped averse
are you but let me just make one very
quick point to Mamun moment moment I've
got to say this you talk about Islam and
mow duty and Acuto the Christian Science
Monitor published a piece in the 1990s
saying that Egypt shouldn't bow down to
Saudi style Islam as a student I saw
fundamentally students go to Saudi
Arabia come back and distribute books
Saudi style fundamentalism unnerved
Egyptians Saudi influence must be curbed
the author of that piece was one man
moon funding
[Applause]
I'm still I'm still I'm uh still to my
point I'm still to my point that you
know influencing young and so on through
money and other things is is we should
become however I have to remind you that
there is a faction of bow to a Saudi
star in Islam matter in this part of our
intelligence squared debate I want to
quickly there's been a very good
question
is there something short of yes well I
if for example I have a say in British
foreign policy I would definitely make
the armed self conditional on Saudi
Arabia respecting international norms I
would I would also lessen the percentage
of arms that Saudi Arabia receives from
Britain and replaced that with exporting
our education and our judiciary
practices that are we are so proud of
independent judiciary is the key to
actually living in peace and having the
real security and stability and on the
export of jihadi propaganda yes of
course Saudi Arabia is responsible in
2001 I was doing research on
transnational religious links between
Saudi Arabia and British Muslims and I
went to one mosque and what do I see
the mufti of Saudi Arabia the head of
the religious establishment preaching to
British Muslims in Birmingham saying to
them you should cut relations with
infidels meaning Christian and Jews
you should not share their celebration
during the two year 2000 because God
forbid your heart might soften and you
begin to love them this was preached on
satellite television to British Muslims
in Burma as a foreign ministry didn't do
anything
one line is the pharmacy I've always
want to be the Prime Minister UK I would
I would do what Bruce Riedel former CIA
officer American exports and Reba said
if the US and the UK tonight told King
Salman that this war in Yemen has to end
it would end tomorrow because the Royal
Saudi Air Force cannot operate without
American and British support think about
that when you vote we could end the war
tomorrow we could end the war tomorrow
ladies and gentlemen sadly discipline is
also part of democracy and we are
running against the clock and believe me
if I had my choice I would I would let
three more of the young idealists with
their hands in the air
ask more questions but do join us
afterwards and come and ask us your
questions and my apologies as well to
the other young idealists in the room
who also have their questions ladies and
gentlemen now is the time to make your
mind up and while you are doing that
it's time to make our summing up
speeches more wisdom from our panel
starting with you crisp and blunt Saudi
Arabia is a horribly complex challenge
for the British Foreign Secretary and in
reassessing our relationship with Saudi
Arabia particularly particularly in
light of the dreadful murder of Jamarcus
og and the detention of these a female
democracy activists and the detention of
all the other activists in the civil
society space over the last year or so
is I think the crucial ground on which
we have got to try and retrieve Saudi
Arabia as a voice and a position for
progress and no one should be under any
illusion about how difficult a task that
is going to be and much of it is going
to turn on the relationship with
Mohammed bin Salman who has collected so
many of the levers of power to himself
the private advice that I gave to the
Saudis I knew was that they needed to
learn the history of henry ii and his
relationship with thomas a becket henry
ii had thomas a becket
related and then he went to do penance
for that and then he was a wiser and
better King as a consequence now of
course there should be accountability
but then we also in the hard world of
foreign relations and international
diplomacy that has to be also measured
with a degree of achievable practicality
whether that is achievable in Saudi
Arabia now I do not know much of it is
going to come out of the story that then
comes out but the actual culpability of
Mohammed bin Salman what is established
for what happened with Jamal khashoggi
but as far as the whole Saudi Arabian
government is concerned I think it is
necessary for us to continue to engage
to try and support progress towards an
economic vision of 2030 which I think
all should be supported and it should be
a lesson upon those we're trying to make
the view about Saudi Arabian society
that women in Saudi Arabia have been
part of the education and the progress
of Saudi Arabia in a way that you will
never really hear in in a kind of debate
like this and any foreign companies
going to want to invest in Saudi Arabia
will always usually seek to employ a
Saudi Arabia woman at first because of
the work and contribution they make to
their society hundreds of thousands
millions of scientists have now been
educated in the West and have inculcated
the values of openness and democracy and
taken them back home to their country
are we really going to cut all those
ties and end that possibility of
progress and a closer alignment of Saudi
Arabia with our values
[Applause]
now in Russia yes of course you have
been subjected to the Saudi propaganda
in the media regardless of what's been
said that the good Saudi voices are not
heard but when the ban on driving was
lifted by Mohammed bin Salman and I
wasn't very happy because I knew that if
I was in Saudi Arabia I will be able now
to drive myself to prison so in terms of
Thais cutting the ties or not giving the
Saudi regime unconditional support which
is my position I strongly believe that
still the British government and other
Western government can exert pressure on
Saudi Arabia to respect international
law to treat its own citizens with
respect to give them the opportunity to
have a representative government we have
had enough of the rule of princes the
British government since 1902 when it
struck that alliance with the House of
South could only think about the tall
shake the oil-rich Sheikh and remember
they empowered the Assad regime from
1902 until the establishment of the
kingdom supporting them with arms you
just need to go to the public record
office and read the archives and you
know today what extent the British
government continued to support the
House of Saud when it was launching
jihad yes the Saudi state is the first
jihadi project in the Middle East it's
the first state that was founded on
jihad meaning before they got their
attention into the so-called
infidels they were fighting Sunni
Muslims which are the majority in Saudi
Arabia killing people in mosques and
also accusing them of blasphemy to
spread the hegemony of the House of Saud
and that was done with the British
government support so I hope today the
situation is this
and the British government will rethink
its relationship with this regime that
it had created in at the beginning of
the 20th century
Magoon Fondy realistic getting more I'm
sickened as a good Muslim I like to
think not not a hundred percent but is a
good Muslim I'm very offended actually
by the building of concepts has charged
me hide etcetera in Islam that became
almost at robotics
to trashes publicly and somehow this is
a fad that we are going through I think
this is very offensive there are 1
billion Muslims who think of the word
jihadis Taha'a and thought of it as to
teach our children men and women and
Cendant university etcetera it's about
jihad enough fighting your inner demons
etc these amazing things about Islam and
it's a fantastic face that shouldn't be
just trashed the way I listen to it as
Saudi Arabia is just one small part of
the Muslim world and probably the least
populated but the Muslim world most most
Muslims are non Arabs they live in
Indonesia and and Malaysia and India etc
so the idea that somehow Islam it's
became an open season on Islam by
attacking sorry or taking issue like
democracy and turning it into the way it
is I'm really worried about the
excitement's of people sometimes if
people were were not that excited to win
the Archduke Ferdinand was killed in
Sarajevo we'd never had when you take
like one person on the example and worse
personal issue and charge it with
emotions
I don't suddenly get too excited and and
try to push government to make the wrong
decisions I think this is very dangerous
we have to as as Caspar said we have to
think of constructive engagements of
countries who might end up being grow
and will change their behavior we have
to
inform policies and and move countries
for it is so ironic that a Saudi Arabia
opens and my friend Maggy quotes me 1990
when I was not really a fan of State
Arabia at the time and I had more hair
than than this there are more than
Maddie but it is that Saudi that I
didn't like us Saudi Arabia as it opened
up now it is time to encourage Arabia to
open up even more and inform its
policies with with with reason and
become part of the international
community rather than isolating it thank
you
30 rcent back to you the last the West
should cut ties with Saudi Arabia I'll
be honest I preferred the Mamoon Effendi
of 1992 but that's just me ladies
gentleman my question for you tonight as
you vote is very simple are you going to
turn a blind eye to the costs of our
ongoing Alliance and friendship with one
of the most repressive countries in the
world one of the biggest sponsors of
terrorism one of the most reactionary
misogynistic anti-semitic sectarian
countries on the planet or are you going
to vote in favor of what are quite mild
consequences for the Saudis we're not
talking about regime Jen Crispin did we
didn't bring it up we're just talking
about the cutting of ties for the ending
of red carpets for the suspension of
arms sales don't listen to the
fear-mongering of the Opposition of
Crispin Blount who tells us that if we
stopped selling bombs to Saudi Arabia
there'll be a revolution inside the
kingdom which seems rather bizarre to me
for a man who's such a big supporter of
brexit he's given us a lot of project
fear tonight and this isn't just about
human rights this isn't just about human
rights this is about interests as well I
mentioned early Republican Senator
Lindsey Graham a hawk who was once a big
backward Saturday he says he cannot
carry on supporting salary but under
reckless MBs he says we don't want to
give a green light to others that they
can go down this road that's what we're
asking you to vote for tonight don't
give them a green light vote for
consequences vote for accountability
vote for justice I'm sorry I know my man
wonders like this but vote for justice
for Jamal we are talking about real
people here Jamarcus Shaw who walked
into a Saudi consulate in Istanbul five
months ago was surrounded by a team of
Saudi assassins who put a plastic bag
over his head his last words reportedly
were do not cover my mouth I have asthma
don't you will strangle me
vote for Jamal tonight vote for all
those names you heard tonight vote for
the motion thank you very much for your
time
ladies and gentlemen no matter how you
voted tonight no matter what your view
tonight
before the debate or after the debate
you have all young and old idealist or
cynics confirmed again the importance
the essential nature of impassioned
inspired and most of all of intelligent
debate and such is intelligence squared
how did you vote when you came in
tonight 41% of you said you were for the
motion that the West should cut ties
with Saudi Arabia 22% of you were
against 37% of you came into manual
center tonight not quite sure what you
thought and what have you decided at the
end of our evening 63% of you are for
the motion
only five percent were undecided 32% of
you were against the motion that was a
swing ladies and gentlemen of six
percent for the motion the West should
cut ties with Saudi Arabia thank you to
our excellent panelists for the motion
and against the motion and thank you to
all of you for all of your questions and
your participation
[Applause]